[Music]
oh god
oh one of the residents of uh
was one guy still in business
he's like i gotta stay open
we never closed
whether wind or rain or rancor
or raycor he's crazy
he's like he offers a record hey can you
not step on my business look got to move
these melloroon i'm a small business
owner times have been tough
oh
that's not true that's from the
christmas special
that's a that's a shocking rematch from
the christmas special yes he's got the
stirrups in there like
yeah
this is cool
what if you just ate him that's what
what was the movie deep blue sea
like it's dead or no uh the first
pacific rim when uh ron perlman's
character is like oh right this thing
stinks and then it bites it eats it
they would never do that no that would
be
and also you've got to love the second
city reunion there persuasion is the
strangest with candy all right back
together did swayze do a bit on her true
tv show too we're using the shirt
i mean they've been friends for like 40
years
yeah it's so sweet these two can like
can we just have a scene together
i just love how the music is fit
this whole time
who's getting that bath i figured bk
wouldn't fit in there no
oh cobb man oh you're a turtle neck why
is his hair so nice he looks like billy
bob
it looks like a billy bob thornton
character
welcome back to new rockstars the book
of beaufett has turned its final page
and we did finally get a book in this
show even if it was just boba fett's
handwritten note to dave pasquez's major
domo telling the pikes to write off is
boba fett promising nothing really the
deeper metaphor of the series in what
ways did this series ending leave the
star wars universe changed and unchanged
we're gonna break it all down as we ask
what the fact that
this is wookiee leaks new rockstars book
of boba fett after show and our weekly
reaction the latest in star wars i'm
eric boss my easter egg breakdown is
coming tomorrow but right now i'm here
to help you process and work through
this finale all seven of these episodes
with my favorite star wars fanatic tommy
bechtold
ah yes eric no you know me i'm a big
shakespeare guy and i guess what i could
say about this entire series is it was
full of sound and fury
signifying nothing
or i mean
i understand why people have mixed
reactions coming out of this but i kind
of approached it the way like mj does
everything it's spider-man no way home
yeah your expectations low you never get
to never be disappointed and i kind of
figured after the episode five episode
six i just kind of accepted the way they
structured this season is really really
weird and i'm just going to sit back and
enjoy the ride because i knew we were
going back to tatooine and i figured
their big cameos were already spent like
at that point i would have been shocked
if we had like
dh han solo yeah or if we had akira show
up i held out but the fact that cad bain
showed up that felt like the big cameo
so i was just like okay we're just gonna
get a battle between boba fett's united
forces and the pikes maybe we'll get
some uh tuscans coming over the ridge i
don't know
um and at the end of the day i think i
overall enjoyed it i'm happy with this
i'm not going to get i'm not going to
get too burned by this you know i did
too like you can't really i mean i know
i like all kidding aside like you can't
tell me that we're going to get a cad
bane in black chrysanthe appearance in
this show in a seven episode show and
didn't have me end up being like well
i hated it like i think that was to me i
thought it was i thought that the both
of those editions were were excellent i
like that black chrysanthemum is still
out there i think he's a great
live-action
uh addition to this saga he can show up
on any show it feels like and be kind of
a menacing or
sigh of relief
enforcer uh so yeah i i you know i i
overall i think i enjoyed it too that
was not a beginning middle and end that
was kind of just a here is some more
star wars
exactly this is this is the world we're
in now both in marvel and in star wars i
would say with this season of boba fett
it feels like this is the case more with
star wars it just reminds me of being in
the middle of clone wars or in the
rebels and you would have these random
arcs that just kind of felt disconnected
from other things but you're still
grateful for experiencing it i think
that's bologna's bigger vision is that
you can just drop in on characters as
they're going on their journeys and just
kind of follow where they go and i think
for people who expect a mini series that
has like this really tight arc uh a
character journey i would say on boba
fett it was there it was not as
pronounced as it was on something like
on uh loki or wandavision or like my
favorite show for the past year uh
station 11 which makes me cry when i
think about it because it's so perfect
but um
but it did feel like i got to drop in
with boba fett for for i guess what
ended up being five episodes i got to
get an episode with luke and grogu i got
to get an episode with mando and
learning more about the dark saber and i
i'm grateful for that journey and if
that's all these star wars shows are i
as long as some of them might give us
this arc i imagine this obi-wan kenobi
series will probably give us that i'm
okay with that like honestly i it just
gives me an excuse to hang out with you
every week and you know what
i'll take a million shows that don't
have anything that don't have any
beginning middle or end if we get to
hang out every week and talk star wars
you know what
sometimes they can just be shows we make
up puppet shows
yeah i mean look all of this all of this
is just like ways that tommy and i can
trick phillip and our other bosses into
just like hey there's a new star wars
show coming out yeah you better cover it
but we've been doing like seven
pre-episodes yeah
exactly and and to that point you can
actually see tommy and phillip and me
and jessica clements we are so excited
to be headed to chicago this friday for
our special live show with rooster teeth
very normal podcast store we're going to
be joining the great team at the face
jam podcast uh and we're we're sharing
this live show that's going to be friday
february 11th two days from now 8 p.m
tallian hall if you're in the chicago
area you got to check it out it's going
to be a blast tickets are still
available i i'm just putting the final
touches on the show we did a run through
earlier this week we were laughing the
entire time i think it's gonna be so fun
so fun i got a fun new jacket that i'm
gonna wear guys
guys if for nothing else just get the
cheap tickets and come see the jacket
and walk out after i get out there
just a glimpse of the outerwear and then
get out of there it's worth braving the
harsh cold weather to see the city
jacket's not gonna disappoint guys and
there will be a meet and greet with the
jacket not me though
the jacket the anatomy carbon rod of the
rockstar steve it's tommy's jacket
um
well uh tickets are still available uh
check the link in the description and uh
let's recap what happened this episode
so in this finale episode we actually
begin in the bombed out ruins of the
sanctuary in boba growls we are at war
and they are joined by mando uh vedic's
like that was fast and he's like yeah
well i wasn't allowed to talk to the
student it was more like you just kind
of observe on the other side of the
window
his kindergarten teacher said if i if i
interrupted he was just going to want to
leave class and then he'd never go back
to kindergarten again
so i'm going to help you fight this war
so what's going on you got everything
squared away right so suicide mission
for me then sounds great i'd love that
and he promises then that the free town
garrison is on his way and i just wanted
either finnick or boba just to be like
them
yeah that's supposed to do right those
ranchers that dozen or so ranchers i saw
like two houses in that town then
also why is boba so agreeable he's like
like like uh uh mando is like they call
it freetown now and he's like well then
tell freetown where we are grateful for
them and it's like he he didn't go like
no i'm still calling him he's like no
actually call it bobaville it's called
bobaville now we're wasting it away
again in bobaville
drinking out of my watermelons and sand
[Laughter]
well uh boba's like yeah they're coming
he does not yet know that cobb vance has
had this duel with cad bane um but it
sounds like no one knows that cop van
was it a shot in the shoulder the mod
squad arrives and they start figuring
out where they're gonna use their base
of operations bubba wants to fall back
to the palace thinking that would be the
strategically advantageous place to do
it uh but they're like no no we gotta
stay in the town we gotta we gotta show
the people the town we gotta show those
four different fruit vendors yeah that
we have their backs that's right we're
going to let all of this
members who hate us that's right
the people who
a couple people stephen f root who you
know is just waiting for boba to die oh
he's just he cannot he can't wait to
work with the pike syndicate so
meanwhile in maz eisley cad bane meets
with the leader the pike syndicate uh
played by phil lamar and the mayor of
moscow of course voiced by robert
rodriguez who also directed the finales
there too and the pike leader lets cad
bane in on the truth that it was not
that nicto speeder gang that murdered
the tuscan family of boba but it was
actually the pikes who framed them as we
suspected they staged it to look like
the biker gang had done it he they just
appropriated their little symbol and
both of it
bought right into it and took them out
and it was all this this cruel thing
brought up by the pike saying like we
need to look out for our margins we
gotta cut out some overhead here sorry
guys it was a business decision so then
we cut to an x-wing approaching mos espo
usually a sign of some official
interference she even thought it was
captain carsontiva but it was
no one other than grogu and r2d2 this is
crazy that r2 just piloted by himself
grogu just i guess sat in that cockpit
the whole time luke was not going to
join him for this he apparently was
salty over people
i don't know what what happened i wish
they had just shown
grogu picking the chainmail shirt and
luke just being like what the are
you kidding me are you turning down do
you know what this is this is are you
out of your mind
it's yoda's lightsaber you
and he tries to poke him with it he's
like
fine
r2 take him back no i just don't get gen
z i just don't get gen z with their tick
tocks and their chain mail shirts their
best car steal
well then um amy sedaris pelimoto says
my favorite line of the episode grogu
that's a terrible name
she hates it
uh obviously speaking on behalf of the
fans who do not get the name grosgu and
we'll never call him grogu but then
reveals that he is wearing his uh his
best guard chain mail of course so boba
fett's forces start to get into position
the mod squad combing the streets uh
through aqualish territory the gamorean
guards posted at that spaceport black or
santander near city hall in trandoshan
territory uh back in the sanctuary cad
bane walks up so whoever was a lookout
near the sanctuary
was sleeping on the job whoever's
looking out anywhere for k i mean cad
bane is not exactly what i would call
inconspicuous he's a blue man with red
eyes and razor sharp teeth and he just
seems to be able to roll up anywhere
without anyone pushing back they're like
no this guy seems pretty benevolent i
don't think we need to he's a 70 year
old hero
walking straight down the middle of any
road yeah
how did no one spot him he's like ed
harris in westworld and just like
walking like all everyone's just
programmed not to interfere with him so
he can just blow him away whenever he
wants
exactly and uh god bane interestingly
straight up betrays the pikes by telling
boba fett what they did that they were
the ones who took out the tuscans which
was just an interesting point of
contention like it shows that cad bain
is not as interested in working with the
pipes as we thought that really he this
is just personal for him
he wanted to get boba fett's blood
boiling he wanted to lure him into a
duel because he knew that despite his
old age boba fett has missed a few steps
over his time he could smell the back to
fluid on him
i could take him this guy's been taking
a lot of baths lately a lot of
finally boba heeds fenix shan's advice
and says now's not the time i like
seeing this these two finally listen to
each other but then everything falls
apart the aqualish turn on the mod squad
and it looked like it wasn't so much a
trap it was just like a hey we're going
to open our barrels and pull out some
blasters and start shooting this was
like kind of like a bad mafia movie
sequence where it was like all the
families all turned on each other like
where it's like we told you the whole
you couldn't trust each other the whole
time but like nobody was really being
that discreet about it they all just
kind of like we're like yeah we've been
standing in basically an attack position
for the last five minutes and now we're
just pulling our weapons up yeah uh same
thing with like the trained oceans
versus black chrysantheans against the
gomorian guards those poor gomorians
falling out oh squealing all the way
down
it didn't have to scream all the way
down they should have done a wilhelm
scream just for no reason they did one
later
scream late this episode but what if but
if it was a gamorian that was like ah
that would have been great yeah this all
felt just like a little weird like i
didn't know that black cursanton's goal
was to fight any trouble that came like
you would think if they were just there
as lookouts and they're they shoot and
then they run back to report the
gomorians they should they were standing
on the edge of a cliff and then these
platoonians just stood on the other side
of a train
and then that was enough like that it
just the whole system feel like a felt
like a really bad plan like also set up
to be doomed one thing that we know is
that after the clone troopers ran out
the stormtroopers must have been mostly
staffed with aqualish and mod squad
because none of those people could hit
each other with their blasters they were
shooting at each other for like a solid
two minutes of tv time and there were
like zero fatalities or zero even people
getting winged some of the mods some of
the mods got hit and taken out for sure
but there's all the red shirt mods yeah
the red shirt
the red the red shirts are the red
shirts so at the sanctuary boba fett
actually gives mando and out i thought
this was a touchy moment saying like you
can fly off world this isn't your fight
and then says it's against the creed and
he says that they're going to go down
together i thought this was really sweet
yeah and i thought it only makes sense i
thought this was like a good way of
connecting from the past episode that
like at this point it shows that mando
is okay with grogu living his life with
luke that he's he made his acceptance he
no longer really has that purpose if
grogu doesn't need him so he's like okay
this is a good a good of his way to die
as any so i'm gonna go down with another
guy mandalorian armor i think that's an
honorable way to go i mean the armorer
hates me paz-visla hates me yeah i might
as well go down with this guy boca tan
is probably gonna try and kill me one of
these days
[Laughter]
right god knows what apollo creed is
doing on off world
who knows
uh so they say they quote the entirely
episode we're both going to die in the
name of honor but the major domo our
improv legend dave squeezy said hey
an
alternative
the art of negotiation
uh and he's gonna bring boba fett's
terms of surrender and i love boba's
choice here yeah sure yeah
right
it was
so good he was like
sounds good
yeah the squeezy did not read the whole
thing he just
literally read it like on prompter ron
burgundy that whole tablet until he got
to the ward
uh realized that this guy was screwed i
i honestly loved this moment i'm gonna
go i'm gonna go into uh more but this
might have been my favorite moment of
the episode just because like i know
some people find the twilight major demo
a little annoying i think dave is crazy
is brilliant and all the choices he
makes yeah just
so funny where he's like pausing he's
like correcting himself mid-sentence
rolling his eyes and it's like i think
that they're just like in in big fantasy
epics like this you're not used to a
kind of like such a such a comedically
like big sniveling
kind of bootlicker character you know
what i mean like usually that character
is played with like a like kind of a
vile twinge where they're like yes my
lord and then like as soon as the lord
turns away they're like and i've
poisoned your milk or something like
that dave pasquazi is just like he glad
hands he's like a total politician he
smiles at everyone even when they're
insulting his appearance and like saying
things that like i'm sure the twilight's
are borderline racist he's just like ah
that never gets old and like he just
continues
it's just relentless positivity he's
like the ted lasso of star wars
characters yeah or you know you
mentioned like it probably was the case
that piscuazzi and amy sedaris were cast
in these shows
through their connection with john
favreau back in their improv days in
chicago absolutely i think it's the case
but i think directly sarah haley finn
probably looked at uh pasquez's work on
veep as selena meyer's ex-husband and
it's just this kind of like
piece of the way everyone on that
show is just playing the same game yeah
and he played this game on the book of
boba fett now and i don't know if
everyone on the show was playing this
game but like pizza did the homework i
watched his character on the show he did
great um well they're about to kill this
major domo boom that totally set him up
to die which i just think was so funny
he knew what they were gonna do to him
but they end up using that as a stalling
tactic so uh denjarin and boba fett jet
pack in and they just go to town like
gimli and legolas but without the
counting i would have liked a bit of
counting it would have been fun if they
just counted up through mandoa numbers
you know
but as they become outnumbered they do
get some backup from you know the dozen
or so neighborhood watch members of
bobaville retown led by the week way
proprietor w earl brown who we learn his
name tanti
giving everyone time to rally hold off
the first wave of the pikes the mods
make it back infinix shan saves the mods
that was nice to see yes that was cool
and says manners i like that lowers down
her even though we've seen her face
before reveals a little more of her face
but there's uh it seems like they've won
the first wave of the battle but it's a
false victory because the scorpionec
annihilator droids show up these
terrifying droids have been referred to
in star wars canon but never actually
seen in any tv show or movie they're
based on a piece of concept art for star
wars attack of the clones but eventually
morphed into another design but here
they are huge hulking fully armed
impenetrable force field protecting them
reminiscent of the because in phantom
menace but even bigger and even harder
to penetrate
i kept waiting for
and then schwarzenegger just to show up
naked like just blasting through one of
those time-traveling bubbles
[Laughter]
i mean it would be whoever got out of
the back to tank just kind of wet your
gardorians are dead
hang up the phone
well pelimoto shows up in one of those
espca chariots you know yeah it's just
like hey look who's back it took me back
to my harness racing days at batavia
downs eric it was really heartwarming
also she whipped the droid at one point
and i'm like wow
she yeah she did she threw the thing to
it she mushed him and it worked he went
faster well bobo shows up right in the
rancor
one of my other favorite moments of this
episode leading us to this insane kaiju
battle between the rancor and the
scorpionic droid just smashing the city
to bits uh the droid shields do
eventually get weakened we get this like
interesting rationale with the shields
are like oh our kinetics have too much
velocity so like black chrysanthemus to
slowly go through it which felt like
another just take from dune right like
they have to slowly move forward through
the shields in order to penetrate them
right like it's not about like using
blasters to go through yeah also i
forgot to mention earlier in this black
chrysantis
laser knuckles that he uses in the fight
are i i don't know if we can invent that
technology but like i dream of one day
hitting someone in the face with like a
lightsaber brass knuckles
those things were awesome yeah those
things were some of my new favorite
weapons of the show well the shields do
get weakened uh amanda's able to get in
there with a dark saber finally but
doesn't go over the eye he just starts
slashing away at anything it seems like
groga is going to take it down but just
pulls a bolt out of it as a toy yeah
which is such a great moment you know i
love that
it was amazing and it just gives amanda
enough time to get out of there so
they're finally able to just smash this
thing and i love that it did it
just pulled it apart yeah what a great
moment there so uh this leads to boba
fett and cadbad having their
long-awaited showdown and uh if you were
a fan of star wars lore you know that
clone wars creator dave filoni
envisioned the showdown between these
two characters that was part of the
unfinished season six arc uh where it's
gonna be a younger boba fett and cad
bane uh that was gonna lead to the
dent that you see in boba fett's helmet
uh the showdown's finally happening but
i think cad bain asked a question we've
all been wondering what's your angle why
are you doing this why do you care about
saving this town uh and boba fett
assures him really there is no angle he
just says this is my city and cat bane
takes him down
he had him he had him clear in his
sights but what saves boba fett in this
moment not the tuscan raiders actually
being still alive it was all represented
in the gappy stick that's right i will
say it felt satisfying to see him defeat
him with the gaffy stick yes but did he
have to kill cad bane i'm a little
bummed yeah that's cad bane as a
character but is anyone ever really dead
luke promised us in the first trailer of
uh
the last jedi no one ever really dies
yep uh i mean that overhead shot of cad
being just laying lifeless i wanted him
to just go
yeah
slither away like exorcist style on his
back
jesus that guy is so creepy well now we
gotta deal with the issue of this
rampaging rancor right so he climbs the
tower full king kong mode throws a
speeder at boba fett's amassed forces
beats the hell out of mando until grogu
comes in and looks at the beast
and it is the most striking image of the
entire episode when he's able to yes
just put this to sleep and then nuzzles
up to it with a little nap what a
beautiful little moment what a little
what a cute little munchkin now i just
every time grogan moved in this episode
i just went ah
and then someone would die
so uh fennec shan takes out the other
remaining forces mare maches the pike
leader does that the the godfather
baptism sequence there but i'll just
keep in one room so now we're back in
the streets of mos espa and boba and
finnick walk the streets getting some
respect from the townspeople he waves
back uh doesn't salute him back just
kind of waves does a little
queen
why is it going to be my right arm he
says someone is using the back tank
right now but it's not black or santan
who i thought it was going to be he
shows up right there uh and then we get
to see the rat catcher droid come back
and they're all just kind of hanging out
it's great but then we cut to mando in
grogu in the astromech sports of the
naboo starfighter it's great and then we
get the sweet little mando style moment
between the two of them where he's like
okay one last time and he uses the
sublight thrusters oh god and you know
what put that on loop cause it was so
cute it was so adorable and then we do
get a post-credits scene or mid-credit
scene where we do see who's in the back
tank it is cobb van wearing a weird
steve jobs style turtleneck yes and
perfectly
yeah i don't know
it's like uh no we don't need you to
change timotheola fans like i could take
off my shirt but why give away the goods
that's right i think i feel like they
were setting him up just in case he
needed to go do an episode of inside the
actor's studio right after
they're like we gotta have you fully
hair and makeup ready
and he's there with our guy thundercat
yeah ready to do some mod uh art on this
guy turn him into a mod give him the
he's like give me the fennec give me the
thinning but what does he need i don't
know like does he just need like a
little like plate on his shoulder like
he's just kidding it just needs yeah he
means my dad got that surgery last year
from thundercat and is his life not
better as a result
no
no he's constantly he's fighting off
aliens in the desert so what are we
meant to take away from this finale what
was the true book of boba fett i have
some thoughts on that but first our
friends at epic hero shops still have
some shirts available inspired by boba
fett this latest obsession will be
returning to the sarlacc pit soon so you
gotta jump on it when you do you'll get
the added option to write in a custom
shout out that will appear on screen
during these wikileaks episodes we got
david saying amazing cameos this season
hoping to see more bounty hunters in
live action specifically durge agreed
that would be really fun in a future in
a future season because you know we're
just going to have new seasons coming
out with all these characters whatever
ends up being called
michael says star wars is at its best
when 3po isn't around to annoy everyone
wow wow
some shade
[Music]
michael
he might i i understand what michael's
saying when it comes to clone wars
and these 3po episodes of clone wars are
really hard to get through they're just
they're meant for kids not meant for
grown men watching kids shows grown-ass
men watching cartoons about star wars
baby and then franklin says could you
guys tell my friend to watch clone wars
the tv show thanks guys love the content
am i your friend franklin because my
answer is still no
watch clone wars just so you can
understand these shows better right okay
clone wars has so much good stuff in it
all right what was our question coming
out of this episode eric
one last time for this specific
structure
what the fit was the book of boba fett
yes what was this show we we did joke
about it in the intro but i really do
think that note that bobo wrote for
besqueazy's twilight major domo to read
to the pikes was
kinda the perfect symbol of what the
book of bobo fed as a series was really
all about because yeah we gotta be
honest this series was weird it was
structurally insane in filoni's overall
vision for these interweaving series
this was really the mandalorian 2.5
without a doubt like it'll be more
remembered for what we learned about the
dark saber the fate of mandalore about
grogu
i forgot about school
yeah yeah you forgot about it now after
this episode but as we you know have new
seasons coming out we're gonna think
back on those things i don't really
think we're gonna think that much about
everything that happened on tatooine uh
i think we learned some really cool
stuff about tuscan uh mysticism uh i
think we learned some interesting stuff
about the city of moscespa but and then
we got some cool new characters showing
up but overall i think we're going to
think more about the revelations about
grogu about the darksaber as always
these are the stars of these of these
disney plus series so why do we spend so
much time on tattooing why structure
these episodes with extended flashback
does and then these tuscan spirit quests
that ultimately by the end of this
episode just really live on in stick
form and then and then episode after
episode watch boba fett falling upwards
falling upwards literally out of the
sarlacc in the opening images and then
almost falling back into the sarlacc and
then falling upwards against a criminal
network composed of huts and pikes and
wookies enduros who are all
smarter and deadlier than he is was this
all really just so groggy could take a
nap beside a rancor and cop vance could
end up in a back to tank as thundercat
turns him into a classic characters fans
like the least in this miniseries now
i'm sure many of you are commenting
right now saying i'm hating on this show
but i hate to disappoint you while it is
easy to feel that way you know what i
don't feel that way i enjoy this after
covering so many of these disney plus
seasons i've now learned to know when to
keep one's expectations in check and i
knew i just knew after those insanely
packed episodes five and six there was
just no way a return to tatooine would
top those levels of fan service and so i
quite enjoyed this rancor versus dratica
giant droidika
kaiju
i thought it was super fun i
you know i'm hearing a lot of like
armchair film school analysis saying
that robert rodriguez doesn't know how
to direct action they use they keep
calling the spy kids and it's like
ronda rousey is a pretty good action
director yeah i think there was a lot of
there's a couple other examples you're
leaving out of his
repertoire when you just narrow it down
to spy kids he uh i think there's a lot
of things going on behind the scenes of
the show why it was structured this way
i think they probably found out midway
through that the character of boba fett
from a writing standpoint and lucasfilm
as a whole didn't have a clear
take on what this character's chief
motivation was
uh might have gotten scared halfway
through and decided to restructure it
halfway through and brought in the big
guns of felony of bryce dallas howard to
direct some of these things and and
really robert rodriguez was left to just
do cleanup work and
to his credit it often doesn't feel that
way got a lot of people on twitter
saying he cut there's so many cuts in
this there's so many edits you don't
know how to direct action if you have to
edit so much it's like mother
what is the best action film in the past
decade mad max fury road you know how
much george miller cut in that movie he
cuts constantly and it's gripping and
it's amazing because editing is
filmmaking you do have to cut not every
not a single long take makes a good
movie if anything a long take is just a
flex by a director and how well they
block things on their sets a long take
doesn't often make a good uh
good direction watch the opening shot of
spectre which has the random stupid long
take which tells you nothing about
character long takes it doesn't mean
good directing editing well i would ask
anyone who's ever worked on a show or a
movie that does a long take it's
miserable it sucks
it's really miserable it's great
when they pull it off and it tells you
something about the character yeah other
than that it's just a director just like
that it's a lot of you going oh my god i
can't believe we have to do this again
yeah exactly um so i i think robert
rodriguez is a great director i don't
know everything that was going on behind
the scenes but i think he put together
something that was super enjoyable at
the end of the day but i will say i did
have a gripe i mean i ate a few gripes
right i have a few gripes with all these
shows one thing that i feel like was a
missed opportunity that bummed me out
was in this big face-off between boba
and cad bane we got zero mention of
their past duel that resulted in the
dent in boba's helmet like
he did say he mentioned to a past where
he's like oh you're not a younger kid
anymore or whatever right but like why
can't they just talk about the dent why
does it because we're never if cad bain
is dead that's never going to come up
again not to see say we can't see it we
could see that station live action
earlier in their lives but i just would
have liked some reference to it um but
other than that that's it like i didn't
need dh han solo or kira or bo katan or
rex or omega or mace windu like i would
have liked maybe a rohirrim of tuscans
coming over the ridge just to redeem
their unceremonious slaughter earlier
this season but ultimately i suppose
boba beating cat with the gappy stick
was enough of a victory there uh i just
keep coming back to the exact words of
boba
that he wrote for the major domo to read
to the pikes
and the more i rewatch that clip i
really think it is a kind of gospel for
how the book of boba fett actually
resulted in some permanent change or at
least his outlook
of an optimistic future for this star
wars universe on tatooine here is what
boba fett wrote super fast by the way he
wrote this all by hand he said
i boba fett speaking as daimio of the
tattooing territories formerly held by
jabba the hutt do present the following
offer
nothing
you will leave this planet and your
spice trade if you refuse these terms
the arid sands of tatooine will once
again flourish with floured fields
fertilized with the bodies
of your dead and the major domo tags it
with a ritualistic the word the lord
but in this case he says
his words
[Laughter]
and
a great moment i think it says it all
that book that right there is our book a
boba fett listen to that poetry
alliteration there flourish with
flowered fields fertilized he wrote that
off the top of his head and i think boba
is alluding to what i find to be the
most fascinating thing revealed about
tatooine on the show something learned
only through boba's experience with the
tuscans on the night of his march to the
gaffey tree and mentioned briefly by the
great stephen of root before he was cut
off that tatooine used to be covered in
oceans and rich vegetation we
did not learn what disastrous event
caused that but we did see something
similar happen on mandalore a planet
bomb to bits probably happened on
tatooine as well yet mandalore still
possesses the living waters underneath
the surface that mando will visit in the
mandalorian season 3. likewise i think
some kind of form of living waters may
exist and can now return to the surface
of tatooine because it was heavily
implied throughout the season that the
reason for its arid state the reason why
tatooine's still a is because
it is used as spice territory now it is
not mine there it's mined on kessel but
it seems like it is brought there to be
processed these drug deals happening
these drug transfers happening they're
they're trains comb through their desert
mowing down banthas in tuscans uh the
deals are happening in the cities
preventing true business opportunities
from flourishing uh and i think the
implication
is that without the huts
or the pikes plaguing this planet a
curse has been lifted so now we may
finally see some natural gaffy trees
springing up imagine the stones being
returned to the indian village in temple
of doom that's kind of what it feels
like that next time we visit tatooine i
guess next time we visit it was later on
when rey goes there in the final scene
of uh ryze skywalker right but i'm
hoping now we can start seeing some more
vegetation we can start to see
tatooine return to that natural state
and at least see some social mobility
for the tuscans uh because remember
there was a line where fenix said that
hey maybe we should keep some of the
spice trading active because the huts
they pay well that's going to be a
profitable thing for us a lot of credits
in that and boba said no no dice on
spice
so i think with spice gone from the
planet that curse has been lifted from
the blood-soaked homeland of the
skywalkers and we've gone from death to
life and that in my eyes is the book of
boba fett but tommy i wanted to ask you
did you feel any of this or do you think
that if that was robert rodriguez's and
john favreau's and and dave felonie's
intention that they could have done a
better job executing it in these
episodes no i think i think that it's i
i almost wonder if the the the returning
of of vegetation or or the returning of
the way
tatooine needs to be is more
metaphorical you know what i mean like
it's more of like a blossoming of of of
this of the people that live there and
the species that all live there because
it
it's always interesting to me the way
tattooing is laid out is like
it's very isolated it's these cities
that are very isolated from each other
with just vast desert in between that
you really can only get to by either
walking through tremendous
heat and and and and just
brutal sun or having some sort of
speeder or some sort of craft so i i
almost wonder if this if it's a symbolic
kind of reawakening of the planet rather
than just a physical we're going to see
vegetation pop up i i feel like it's
more
we can see the tuscans interacting with
the
with the with the cities more the trade
being you know kind of a more
interconnected world it's just you know
making the world a little smaller one
electronic device at the time much like
our world today maybe the introduction
of iphones you know or something like
that to get everybody
to get everybody going but seriously i i
i i think it's a little too like
almost like animated movie-ish to have
had like a spring pop up at the end and
like people be like a kid picking a
flower or kind of almost like a
post-apocalyptic world but
i i
i think it's more the metaphor of
tattooing becoming a thriving planet
again uh with the elimination of spice
get the spice out of there just like my
aunt barb's potato salad at a fourth of
july picnic no spice
no seasoning
yeah i what you're saying is like maybe
a little too cute by half a little on
the nose i would have loved a final shot
i think that returns to those two gaffy
trees in the middle of the dune sea and
then maybe we just pull back and we see
like another
leaf or some kind of taste all right you
know what you you sold me on that image
specifically to do anything there that
was the easiest sell yeah i'm back again
eric i can't say no to you i just look
at your i look at you and your blue
dungeon with your cute mandalorian shirt
or your cupola fetcher and i just i
don't know you sell me you're the blue
dungeon too
you know what let's get back to pod
racing let's let's use the fossil fuels
of pot or whatever rob or or how about
this like you know they're they had the
miller on fruit that uh bk takes a big
bite of at the end like it would have
been more fun i think maybe if those
male run fruits were just a little
rotten as they collapsed on the major
domo in the previous episode and now
it's like ripe suggesting like oh it's
you know this is a more
fortuitous place to do business and to
have uh fresh produce you know it's now
a true farmers market because the
conditions here are starting to improve
with occasional rancor attacks
because here's the deal like before we
got to episode five and episode six of
the series and then that just blew our
minds it was just like kind of like not
cheap fan service
but it felt like
it felt like candy it felt like
halloween you know um before we got
there we were just trying to derive some
meaning of what they were trying to say
about boba's journey with the tuscans
here on tatooine for a second it did
feel like oh this show should just be
called tatooine you know like uh the
tales of tatooine or something like that
or um you know the secrets of tatooine
like the episode two was just so
fascinating to learn like the tuscan
ways their
their mysticism their religious beliefs
their their traditions
i loved that uh and i love a show that
just explores one place i didn't need to
go to space at that point it wasn't
until they just pulled away from the
tuscans and started to visit parts of
tattooing that were not as well defined
and and showed how boba fett did not
really have a clear strategy or a plan
for how he wanted to bring the criminal
uh parts of the city into the fold also
if it is a criminal network
what crime is boba fett overseeing if
not the sale of spice like it's a
criminal network you want to be tony
soprano well you're not truly working in
waste management people are dying and
selling drugs it kind of feels like the
only thing boba wants to do is take
bribes from like nightclub owners like
that's like that's the only crime he's
comfortable like i guess providing
protection
maybe that's right i i loved everything
in the flashbacks way more than in the
present era so as soon as those
flashbacks really ended and his time
with the tuscans really ended that's
when i got confused about what the show
really was but i would i would watch a
show honestly if it was just the tuscans
grunting at each other with their
massives uh doing their journeys of
going to gappy trees like that to me is
fascinating i'd watch that i don't need
an outsider to join them i'd i'd love to
watch just some tuscans worthlessly
grunting at each other talking
about the people over in freetown you
know
uh dealing with the crate dragon dealing
with the sarlacc you know there's a
whole world there and i love that i
would watch a whole show if it was just
tattooing you know absolutely it's when
it tries to do too much where i get a
little lost
um and i think that's where we got a
little lost but still at the end of the
day there's so much great that came out
of this series and i'm grateful for all
that i'm in a good place right now i
agree it was really overall very
enjoyable i you know you can pick it
apart and you can have your complaints
and gripes about it which i'm sure we
all do and like you know you can call
out what worked and what didn't work but
at the end of the day i still left going
like i'm glad i watched that that was
good and i'm looking forward to more
like it wasn't like one of those things
where i left the like the theater going
what the hell just happened
you know
like it was like i understood i got a
sense of like ah okay this was a
different show than i thought after
episode two and i i understand but i
also concluded that in episode five
right right as soon as amanda walked in
with a dark saber i'm like yeah ah this
is a different show than i thought okay
i'm not i'm not bummed about that yeah
we're going to talk some more um but
first we want to thank our friends at
hello fresh our friends at hellofresh
are shipping out farm fresh
pre-proportioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes right to your doorstep
you can save time and money that you can
better use to run your desert planet
criminal empire hella fresh delivers
free proportion ingredients to your door
including farm fresh produce that
arrives within a week so you can get
convenience without skimping on quality
customize your favorite dishes with
their new hello custom offerings by
swapping out one protein or side for
another upgrading for a more luxe
experience even adding protein to a
veggie meal that means more choices more
variety and more meals truly tailored
for you hello fresh is 72 percent
cheaper than a restaurant meal of the
same quality and you can save on average
over 65 dollars a month when you order
hellofresh instead of grocery shopping
that's money back in your pocket because
you're not wasting any ingredients this
way they give you exactly what you need
to make this great meal anytime i try to
use produce in a in a meal i always feel
bad and i'm wasting it's so hard to shop
for the exact amount that you need or
something like that well hello
hellofresh solves that for you we're big
fans of hello fresh in our house i
actually made a shepherd's pie last
night i i'm nervous about making british
cuisine this is the only meal i want to
eat for the rest of my life it was so
good uh so it's just such a great excuse
to try cooking new things in a way that
sets us up for success the food is
always tasty i feel an extra sense of
accomplishment for cooking something new
so you try it yourself go to
hellofresh.com wikileaks16
and use the code wikileaks 16 for up to
16 free meals and three free gifts at
telefresh.com
wikileaks 16 use the code wikileaks16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts we also want to thank peloton for
sponsoring this episode when you're
trying to develop new habits you want to
keep things fresh to avoid burning out
right well our friends at peloton are
helping you keep things fresh by
offering new classes new music new ways
to keep yourself motivated to work out
the folks that make the exercise bikes
that everybody loves also have a great
exercise app and you don't even need to
have one of the bikes to use this app
peloton has a workout for every day and
every schedule de-stressed from a long
day with 30 minutes of strength 20
minutes of cardio or just do a quick
15-minute total body class before work
stay motivated while having fun with
bike workouts yoga boxing dance cardio
and more peloton is offering more great
music to their app including fun new
artist series classes work out to the
music of a single artist for an entire
class from your favorite hits to the
deep cuts i'm excited to try the
meditation classes after a long season
of the book of boba fett i could you
know use some meditation time my own
kind of like app back to tank and that's
what this peloton app does for me it's a
back to tank for my mind so you visit
onepeleton.com to learn more that's
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
and last we want to thank magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode we all love
delicious sweet treats but if you're
trying to eat clean and mean like the
boba of tatooine magic spoon can help
you magic spoon cereal has zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving that's
keto-friendly gluten-free grain-free
soy-free low-carb grab yourself a
variety pack for the four flavors of
cocoa fruity frosted and peanut butter
you can try mixing those flavors
chocolate peanut butter go together so
well it's my favorite combo frosted
fruity go really great together so go to
magicspoon.com wikileaks to grab a
variety pack and try it today and be
sure to use our promo code of wikileaks
to check out to save five dollars off
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
wikileaks and use the code wikileaks to
save five dollars off and again we thank
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
okay tommy i want to ask you after this
final scene where are mando and grogu
headed now
you know uh i think the uh you know
obviously the indicated answer is
they're going to be searching for some
sort of information in those underground
lakes but i think that the beginning
their next their first stop is that
they've got to go be and i know this
sounds ridiculous they've got to go be
present for the trial of moff gideon i
think we're going to see
i think we're going to see them uh not
necessarily grogu take the stand but i
think that they are key
witnesses and key participants in the
crimes of maf gideon not participants i
guess you could almost say victims of
the crimes so i think they are headed to
some sort of new republic outpost
courthouse to uh witness the trial and
let's hope conviction
of the dastardly moff gideon what about
you eric what do you think
i think that's such a brilliant idea
tommy i didn't think about that i was
thinking yeah they're gonna head to
mandalore he's gonna go dig down to
those mines go swimming girl is gonna be
like what are you doing he's gonna be
looking for groceries looking for slugs
to eat
what a fascinating opening scene it
reminds me of um
sherlock series three maybe where uh
where moriarty uh goes through a uh a
criminal court yes proceeding and gets
off like that and gets off in all kinds
of ways that guy is horny in the show oh
he gets off all right
hot priest was once a hot criminal
mastermind that's right um anyway i
would love to see just the collapse and
the corruption of the new republic
because the new republic is not on
stable footing at this point in history
there's a lot of infighting happening
right now to where leia was trying to be
a rallying figure but she has some
political rivals and eventually just
says you know what i'm done i can't do
this you guys are all messed up there's
like
uh plots there's coup plots bombings it
is totally uh plausible that maf gideon
is able to
plea insanity or something like that or
or blame someone else or able to like
because they're trying too hard to make
it fair and just he could use that
new weak untested justice system against
them and get off or just use like
influences that he has in this new
republic uh to say look you know you
need me you know oh maybe he'll he
offers dirt on someone else and then
he's able to use that to get a lightened
sentence and then he breaks out i would
love if the opening scene is just the
kangaroo court yes of maf gideon and
he's able to play that to his advantage
and they will get out
because i order the release of moff
gideon immediately i thank you your
honor and then he goes out and flies
away in his tie fighter and it'll be
great it's like when uh we watched um uh
chernobyl right and chernobyl is like
history uh so but the final episode is
like the court proceedings that they did
to convict the guys who made the
terrible decisions oh they're 30.5
irankin not too bad not great not too
bad um those guys but the whole court
was really just like set up to appease
western scientists to show that the
soviet union was on top of it those guys
were going to be convicted either way
but as you're watching it the way they
wrote and directed that episode it felt
like really scary like oh my god are
these guys going to be able to walk are
things so corrupt that they're going to
walk and i would love to see like a
similar i just want to visit what's
happening in the new republic yeah i
want to see how screwed up it is i agree
um but yeah i think in mandalorian
season three we gotta visit mandalore we
gotta visit the living waters in
mandalore bo katan has to show up right
i wanna see sabine wren uh i believe is
showing up in ahsoka but i believe all
these characters can really just show up
ultimately yeah i want to know what
happens to the dark saber and i kind of
want them to either move on from
mandalore or for us to learn that
mandalore was not truly bombed to bits
you know um i think there are some
further secrets to that planet
i wanted to also ask you tommy uh why
did luke let grogu return to tatooine
unattended other than r2 is luke salty
that grogu chose mando over him i don't
i don't think so i think i think what we
are now seeing is phase two of luke
phase one was kind of petulant impatient
child you know
wanted to get his wanted to get off of
tatooine wanted to go out and explore
wanted things to happen fast didn't want
to do his training so now and then we
know phase three is like old cranky
fed up and like kind of like seeing the
error of his ways almost kind of like a
broken man luke i think in the middle we
have like little mr perfect luke like
little like i am so zen and so centered
and so one with the force that he's just
like i gave you the choice you chose not
to all right r2 get him out i think it
was more i don't think it was an
emotional choice for him i think he was
like i'll train grogu because he called
out for me at the at that jedi site
and and then okay well grogu is still
attached to mando there's nothing i can
do about that but i'm also not willing
to compromise my jedi beliefs to
hybrid train him as a mandalorian
foundling and a jedi youngling
so all right r2 get him back to his
daddy and i i don't think it was i i
don't think it was an emotional choice i
don't think it was salty i think it was
like i hate to say like a business
decision for how luke wants to run the
new jedi i think that's a really good
point tommy and i think one thing we can
take away is that this was a step in
luke's journey to do eventually uh
to build the school and train his nephew
that leads to the events of the sequel
trilogy i i've never been a fan of this
argument that the sequel trilogy needs
to be erased from star wars canon i
understand they are flawed films but i
enjoyed so much about what they did i
would hate hate if those ever got erased
in the same way that i'd be i was really
really worried when they erased all the
eu stuff right when disney took over
luckily now dave filoni's bringing back
all the best he's right he's just like
he's just kind of like dave fellaini's
opened the fires at fire door and he's
been like come on back in come on back
in we're gonna have you cameo in this
episode you exist now we need someone uh
uh like
the way dave felony loves the prequel
area we need some lucasfilm artist who
just loves the sequel area and is able
to re-contextualize it with like a
background a live-action series that
just shows us like gives us more context
to the characters that we saw i don't
know if that will ever happen um but i
did like we're starting to get that a
little bit with like luke's history
after returning the jedi uh and he's
building this school we're only a couple
years out from when he recruits his
nephew ben solo uh and the fact that
groku had to
rebuff him had to turn away from him so
that luke would turn to his nephew and i
think that's a mistake obviously right
because if you're telling a jedi padawan
that they have to detach from all
relationships tell that to your nephew
yeah you're the brother to his mom
you're the son of his grandfather or his
uncle yeah it kind of explains kind of
explains why kylo ren does some of the
things that he does you know i think it
directly explains it i think it's it's
what makes him so conflicted to be
vulnerable to snoke palpatine's
corruption
uh and that's ends up what i mean luke
creates his
own destruction there and you could
blame it on grogo but groga doesn't know
what's going on he's just he's making
the right choices for him yeah who's
just trying to eat frogs and you know
pollywogs but i do love the implication
that that did set up that chain of
events that we see the school the early
days of being built we know what's
coming i also wonder how that x-wing got
back to luke right didn't r2 just really
pilot it remotely i guess like does he
listen to music on the way like is he
just like always through the sky like
[Laughter]
listening to like
whammer
he no he calls me twitter
do you have to talk to me i got a long
flight i gotta do it by myself i need
you to talk to me the whole time babe
stay up with me babe stay up with me i
don't want to fall asleep while i'm
flying this thing yes yes i am listening
my friend
you're not listening we're wrapping up
here we're going to talk more and more
about star wars every week i just want
to give you a chance any final thoughts
you had about the book of boba fett yeah
you know i thought overall there were
two really interesting paths that not to
steal from mallory rubin from the ringer
but like the theme of this and to me the
theme was uh evolving and you had two
very distinct evolutions in this show
you had boba fett evolving
and in the end boba fett only being able
to truly succeed at survival and
defeating uh his enemies by
by by learning from the tuscan raiders
you know like he all of his skills as a
as a uh technologically advanced master
of weapons jet packs blasters missiles
things like that they all felt him and
in the end what he needed most was the
catching people unawares with the
martial arts and and use of the gaffy
stick or the tuscan raiders stick
uh so i thought that that evolution was
interesting that like the road to
educating yourself and bettering
yourself isn't always a linear path
sometimes you have to
you have to experience different
cultures and different things to be able
to succeed at what you want and then and
then the other person that had that
event was grogu who was set on this path
to become a jedi padawan and ultimately
didn't want to wanted to become some
sort of force using mandalorian
foundling something that we haven't
really seen uh put on the screen before
so his path is now he's not done
learning i'm sure that he's still going
to have different teachers that aren't
just
mando i'm sure he'll have other people
in his life helping him shape his use of
the force like he's not going to stop
using the force
we're both hoping that he'll at some
point hopefully wield the the dark saber
but like you know i think that it's just
his path is no longer a traditional path
of being a jedi padawan turned into jedi
knight turned into jedi master it's like
we now have these two distinctly
unconventional paths of of betterment
from these two you know kind of
massively popular character i love the
shout out to valerie rubin over at the
ringer uh mallory and joanna robinson
their ringer after i mean everything uh
on that house of our uh uh what's it
called their multiverse speed uh that
also you have a band doing the instant
reactions yes i that's a huge part of my
diet for star wars like they have helped
me like recontextualize and think deeply
about these characters so definitely
give them a subscription and a listen
they're amazing i think you are right
and i think we're all part of this
experience of
you know clone wars watchers rebels
watchers already understand this we know
it's a patchwork we know sometimes we're
gonna follow characters it's just gonna
feel a bit episodic and sometimes a bit
aimless but if i think most clone wars
watchers were totally fine with this
series like it feels like a better
version of that um but i think if you go
into this expecting
uh you know a very tight six episode
seven episode arc for a character uh as
they make this transition this change in
their life uh it's where everything ties
back into that theme you're not i don't
know if we're gonna get that from this
corner of uh of media you know and i'm
okay with that i don't need this to be
that with the mandalorians first two
seasons
it was also that it did also feel
wandering episodic aimless not really
sure where it was all headed uh but the
difference was we had this core
relationship of grogu and mando that
felt just very simple from the beginning
we knew biologically instinctively what
their needs were and why they loved each
other um we didn't have that core
relationship with bo it's not just about
one character i think you know uh one
thing i learned back when i was trying
to write a lot of film scripts is that
it's not just about one character's
inner journey what uh hooks an audience
is a core dramatic relationship
sometimes that relationship can be a
character's relationship with the two
halves of themselves i thought from the
first two episodes that was going to be
the case that boba's past and his
present uh were going to be
in in war with each other or boba's uh
clone identity versus tuscan identity
versus bounty hunter identity we're
going to be in conflict with each other
or have some kind of relationship i
don't know if that was ever clearly
spelled out in the show i would have
liked to see
more of a relationship between boba and
fenix shand you know two very
interesting characters uh but both kind
of the
quiet stewing gunslinger characters
usually in other worlds so as a
partnership i didn't really ever by the
end of the show understand what their
deal was together and i think that's
what was missing for a lot of general
viewers of the show is they just
wanted to know what was really
motivating boba fett on on a base level
that uh something that we can
universally connect with um and other
than him just saying this is my city the
fact that the tuscans were killed off so
early uh if it was just something as
simple as i want to give tuscans a seat
at the table
um
that's something that we can connect
with
we understand that story we didn't get
that story um so instead we were just
kind of we had to make that adjustment
in our heads of oh this is just this is
just clone wars and that can be
delightful and fun and it's just more
star wars stories and i think once i was
able to make that pivot halfway through
the season i've been coasting for the
rest of the season i fully enjoyed it i
fully appreciated it and uh i'm okay if
more series feel this way i don't even
need them all to be tightly structured
me too
amen a1 no a all of us
in his own words
or whatever the major doubles
well that is it for this episode of
wikileaks but again my easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow a lot of
cool stuff hidden in this episode tommy
and i are going to be back every week to
talk star wars next week we're going to
answer maybe some lingerie questions you
had after this season of boba fett
beyond that we're going to look ahead to
obi-wan kenobi that is coming in may
will the super bowl give us a a teaser
maybe
hopefully that'd be exciting give us
content
and don't forget to check out our
integrated merch options in new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
follow tommy at tommybeckdoll follow me
rockstars subscribe to wikileaks
wherever your podcast thank you for
watching and we have spoken
you